الاوسط. وكذلك في المحيط الهادئ
لمقارعة اعدائها حول العالم. فلم
قوتهم فلم تعد مهمة مقارنة
بروسيا والصين وكذلك المتحدة
واشنطن احادي الجانب من
افغانستان تثير الكثير من
الاسئلة حول علاقة دول اوروبا
بالولايات المتحدة وجدوى
يبدو مريضا حائل اللون وان وجهه
منتفخ وانه يتحرك بصعوبة رغم
وكذلك الحرج الذي تعرض له
الشركاء الاوروبيون اثر انسحاب
لمصلحة واحدة وهي القضاء على
بوتين. فتارة يقولون ان بوتين
الارضية الغربي وعدم تدخلها
فيها. على ان لا يحق للقوى
دول اوروبا ضمن هذا الحلف ما
يجعل منها وصية على الاتحاد
بمواطنيها. هل هي بداية خلخلة
الوحدة الغربية? امريكا عقدة
الاوروبيين. ظلت الولايات
المتحدة البعبع الذي تكرهه
تدخل امريكا في الشؤون الداخلية
للقوى الاوروبية او في اي حروب
وسمي هذا الاتفاق بعقيدة مونرو
او مبادئ مونرو الاربعة وهي عدم
في اوروبا من ان تحويل الدفاع عن
اوكرانيا الى حرب كاملة بالوكالة
عبثا ان وزير الخارجية الروسي
سيرجي لافروف حذر من الخطر الجاد
على الدول الفقيرة بل اضحت الدول
الكبرى في منطقة اليورو تشعر
اوروبا موحدة ومتماسكة حقا لما
فضلت بريطانيا الخروج من الاتحاد
عشرين عاما يا لا بؤسك ايها
اليورو. ولم يعد الاقتصادي يقتصر
وبين داعم على استحياء ويحاول
الوساطة. لقد عرفتم نعم انه
اطلق على قمة في شرق فرنسا
بالجبل الاكل للرجال. حيث سقط في
وبالرغم من ان الحرب بدأت باعلان
النمسا الحرب على صربيا فانه
تعد واشنطن تثق كثيرا بالدول
الاوروبية. اوروبا تثير الشفقة
الامريكية. وهنا تتجه امريكا
لانشاء حلفي ناتو في الشرق
على روسيا. ولكن دعونا نعود
بالزمن للخلف قليلا فالحربان
للازمات المتلاحقة ارتفعت مؤخرا
اصوات تنادي برسم سياسة خارجية
العالميتان كانتا في الاساس بين
دول اوروبا اذا استثنينا امريكا
الاحتياطي الفيدرالي البنك
المركزي الامريكي برفع اسعار
له في عقدين امام نظرائه
الرئيسيين مدفوعا بقرار مجلس
كما اعلن الحلفاء المنتصرون في
الحرب الولايات المتحدة وفرنسا
يسقط اليورو. اصرت امريكا على
حلفائها الاوروبيين ان يكثفوا
الذي دعا الاوروبيين الى التخلي
عن السذاجة واستخلاص العبر من
مسؤولية البدء بالحرب وعليها
تحمل مسؤولية دفع التعويضات
العقوبات الاقتصادية على موسكو
ليتراجع اقتصادها وتنخفض عملتها.
اعلنت الموت السريري لحلف الناتو
على لسان الرئيس مانويل ماكرون
الوقت. كما خسرت المانيا تقريبا
كل مستعمراتها في افريقيا واسيا
الجنوب الغربي. واستقطعت منطقة
الالزاز واللورين لصالح فرنسا.
الغربي او قمعها سينظر اليها على
انها عمل عدائي ضد الولايات
على المانيا انذاك دفع تعويضات
هائلة الماركات الالمانية في ذلك
والحقيقي للحرب النووية. انها
الحرب التي يخافها العالم اجمع
الف شخص في العاصمة التشيكية
براج متهمين الحكومة بايلاء
يعمر طويلا. ياتي الرد من احد
كتابهم. اذا كنتم تنتظرون موت
الاوروبيين قبل مائتي عام كان
هناك اتفاق بين اوروبا وامريكا.
اوكرانيا. دول اوروبا ايلة
للسقوط كما تقول التقارير.
الغربية استعمار اي مناطق جديدة
فيها مستقبلا. واي محاولة تقوم
اهتمام لاوكرانيا التي مزقتها
الحرب اكثر من الاهتمام
المتحدة. وهكذا تم لكن اليوم
تقود امريكا الناتو وتدخل معظم
اليوم. لربما هي المشتركة يا
عزيزي. لكن ومع ذلك لو كانت
منهما تحاول توسيع حدودها على
حساب الاخرى واصبحت اوروبا
شن هجمات الكترونية او حتى
باستخدام اسلحة الدمار الشامل
تتسابق لتشكيل تحالفات اقتصادية
وعسكرية. ادت الى نسبة التسلح.
الفائدة وتعبئة الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين مزيدا من القوات
ويا له من دمار سيحل باوروبا اذا
ما قرر الدب الروسي ذلك. وليس
وفي الشمال الشرقي استقطعت منها
منطقة غرب بروسيا لصالح بولندا.
للحرب في اوكرانيا. وتراجع
اليورو الى ادنى مستوى له في
عالمية رغم انها كانت في اراضي
القارة العجوز وما حولها.
الالزاز واللورين. اقليم لطالما
تنازعت فرنسا والمانيا بينما
اوروبا وتتحالف معه. وتريد
خسارته في الوقت ذاته. يلى تناقض
مستقلة عن الولايات المتحدة وعلى
رأس هذه الاصوات فرنسا التي
كاملة. الم تفعل امريكا ذلك
بالالمان من سرقة المانيا الى
يا لها من مجزرة بشرية. ها نحن
نعود للحاضر. وهنا قد يخشى اخرون
بالمعاناة ايضا في ظل حرب الطاقة
المستمرة مع موسكو بسبب حرب
نتحدث يا سادة واليكم البقية.
الاصدقاء الاعداء. صافرة الانذار
الاوروبي فعن اي وحدة نتحدث.
فدول اوروبا منقسمة بين داعم
الغربية وكيف جعلت من الاعداء
اصدقاء عن دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
وروسيا. اعداء الامس اصدقاء
اليوم. واصدقاء الامس اعداء
الامريكي فانهم يسحبون اليه
وبقوة. كيف وحدت حرب روسيا الدول
فوحدتهم تقترب من الشتات
واقتصادهم يوشك ان ينهار. اما
متواصل وعملة اوروبا في تقهقر
وانحدار. نعم لقد نجحت الخطة
الامريكية سادة. حيث ارتفع
الدولار الامريكي الى اعلى مستوى
تدوي في كليب. هنا الغرب توحدهم
ضد روسيا نعم اوروبا وامريكا
مواصلتها التعامل مع واشنطن على
اساس الشريك الاساسي. ونتيجة
تنشب بينها واعتراف امريكا
بالمستعمرات في نصف الكرة
لكن الذي حدث ان العملتين
الامريكية والروسية في ارتفاع
ماكرون? بلى. ولكن تغيرت لهجته
بداية الحرب الاوكرانية. الدولار
بعضها على بعض. وكانت فرنسا
والمانيا في حالة صراع مستمر. كل
الخيارات الاستراتيجية الجديدة
للولايات المتحدة. الم يقل ذلك
لكنها تبقى حبرا على الجرائد. هي
دول عظمى يقولون بوحدتهم لكن
طعنة الخيانة على باريس. وتثير
الطعنة في الظاهرة التي تلقتها
فرنسا اتفاق اوكوس بين بريطانيا
واستراليا والولايات المتحدة
الحرب تقع فقط على عاتق المانيا
وحلفائها وبذلك حملوا المانيا
وبريطانيا ايطاليا والدول
المتحالفة معها ان مسؤولية اعلان
وفي المحيط الهادئ الى جانب
خسارتها لاجزاء من اراضيها في
بوتين فقد يطول انتظاركم. انه
يتمتع بصحة جيدة كما لو كان
شابا. الم يفعل ذلك? بعد الحرب
العالمية الاولى. فرضت امريكا
ممارسة لعبة اوكي الجليد وان
يديه ترتعشان وانه باختصار لن
الاوروبي ومشاكله. هذا الحلف
الذي جعل من الاعداء اصدقاء
بها دولة اوروبية للسيطرة على اي
دولة في نصف الكرة الارضية
لا احد يستطيع تجنبها فهي تتقد
شيئا فشيئا. مؤخرا تظاهر سبعون
قد يدفع بوتين الى صعيد الصراع
اما بمهاجمة اهداف غربية اخرى او
معركة رهيبة حوالي ثلاثين الفا
من الجنود الفرنسيين والالمان.
المصالح بدأت دول اخرى بالتدخل
لصالح حلفائها ما جعلها حربا
وسرعان ما تدخلت روسيا لتتبعها
المانيا ثم بريطانيا ومع تضارب
سبب تفرقهم. عداوتهم لبعضهم
البعض تم اخفاؤها. لكن كيف ذلك
خيانات تنتشر كالنار في الهشيم
ورغم محاولة هروبهم من الجلباب
ها هم يجتمعون. يتصافحون
يتضاحكون. يقررون وتنشر قراراتهم
ماكون رئيس فرنسا. فلنبحر في
التاريخ قليلا. ففي بداية القرن
العشرين كانت الدول الاوروبية
تبحث عن سبب يجعلها تعلن الحرب
وبقوة لاوكرانيا كبريطانيا وبين
داعم يحاول التباهي كالمانيا
الاجتماعات الطارئة والانتقادات
الحادة والعقوبات الرادعة تهطل
قلوبهم شتى جمعتهم حرب روسيا لكن
في الحقيقة قد تكون هذه الحرب
يا اصدقاء.